[Music]
in beat the Middle's news no idea pause
submitted by needles oh my god backwards
so dog oh there we go yeah I love dogs
Paul McCartney of the Beatles told GQ
magazine a weird sex story you know
before you mean a Paul McCartney Q
writer go like yeah yeah okay I wonder
if he did thank you Paul thank you Paul
Johnson Paul McCartney why cuz it's the
fake politician real Paul McCartney we
believe solemnly that Paul McCartney
died in the nineteen sixties
yyy-you for sit back a minute I don't
what's the name of the documentary Paul
McCartney really is dead oh I don't like
reading and I don't like documentaries
or oh my god oh you like documentaries I
want to stay ignant all right you saying
it they're so interesting I'm kidding I
like your writers in case whoever wants
to watch these blank dr. mineralize I
don't know he's like this doesn't let me
like some movies movies documentaries
are dumb so funny she didn't say that
he said something like them you'd rather
watch a movie movie but this is like how
movies are based off of you know like
real funny that that's what's funny
because one is make-believe yes and one
is history yes what it's not even the
same thing sometimes it's both which is
even better it's even more fun yeah like
the public or anyone yeah she likes
watching movies on our base like that
are really really but he wasn't like
watch you can talk you matter anyway
funny I never knew that well maybe he
doesn't like the member there she'll
like [ __ ]
he doesn't might get me slapstick
comedies he was my comedy and he's gonna
direct our movie
cool
but is a really good director can't wait
keep me great with this good do you want
to [ __ ] on new for that I want to [ __ ]
on everybody perfect you shout out him
right now
but no one else can really [ __ ] on them
[Music]
and I didn't either I said in a complete
fact you like those to come he doesn't
like the kind of counties that we write
though yeah so he doesn't think
documentaries are dumb I never said you
said he doesn't like you added the W
added um those are so that's so
documents are so dumb
did did I say doubt I don't know he's
like anywho maybe she said it's so dumb
because she wants to see it oh yeah yeah
maybe that I don't know because I heard
the word dumb that's what I was
repeating and now they're all gonna
think there's a sex story that looked it
up and see we're totally beefing not
let's sit let's sit let's switch see
yeah exactly
oh you people with my man such a good
kid actually I am more curious about
what's so crazy yeah like what is the
crazy thing here yeah so the reason why
this story was titled deep the needles
because not like meets the Beatles
because oh he beat us me the story was
that they would had like they would
often or not often actually he recalled
this one time when he went to John
Lennon's home and then there was like
three other of John's friends there and
they were together in a really dark room
and that they instead of getting drunk
and partying they were just all in these
chairs and someone just started
masturbating more than everyone started
master felt like a circle jerk that is
not weird though that call circle jerk
for that time I don't know I wasn't born
during that time I think no matter what
that's pretty weird no
like back it so like late 60s early 70s
you had the [ __ ] wild child and at
the LSD experimenting and love is like
this is before they went famous by the
way oh that's [ __ ] weird they're
famous okay it's weird in any context I
think I know yeah I don't know I think a
bunch of guys just women addiction I'm
beating off but if they're on drugs
you're like that's [ __ ] weird I was
like normal people joke it's better
party yeah instead of all that they just
were sitting and you're gonna remember
when the Beatles first came out this was
the 50s and they were cleaner it wasn't
till the later years that they were more
like that flower child straight up
that's what I was saying late sixties or
seventies yeah I know so then they were
saying that it was just one person just
started masturbating so then they all
did it and then the funk then they
started to have anything like they
collaborated in the jerk because they
would just start screaming out really
hot girls names like Bridget Bridget
Bardot and then they'll be like whoa and
then everyone would just leave my god
[ __ ] I just pictured them in their
Blazers with their bowl cuts just
[ __ ] in that era it's not the long
hair but yeah yeah with a [ __ ] tie on
and they're just jacking off it's like
that size and everything thank you and I
Liverpool I'm from Liverpool and then so
this article that they're talking about
this person writing this started talking
about other people's experiences with
like just straight dudes jerking off in
the same room and it's just it's it's
just [ __ ] weird I've heard of this
I've heard of this well this happens a
lot in the military and probably also in
jail but like what you're knowingly
doing it yeah happens a lot I've never
participated in it but it happens a lot
we're like a bunch of dudes are together
for extended period of time you just get
really comfortable with each other you
start sharing porno and then pretty soon
you start jacking off together and it's
like it's a it's like a normal thing
it's like oh I gotta get my [ __ ] out she
has to get his [ __ ] I'll just do it
together be friends about it yeah what
about doing it for each other because
I'm one of these stories they were
stroking each other they were choking
each other circle jerking that might be
the best level of it
I can see how it gets that it's just
like a hand dropping could be so their
hand dropping each other's what you say
in the like one of the people in these
stories not the Beatles yeah that's
called mutual masturbation but are they
are they are they getting off to each
other are they getting off to each
other's hands are they imagining
something else on the inside
I don't you could just masturbate with
their left hand that's true worry what
you do is you fall asleep on the right
hand and then you masturbate with your
head was my left hand so much that now
the right hand feels like a stranger oh
that's like my side chick became like my
main chick interesting I knew what we
knew a guy that told us about I started
like that where they were him and his
homies they were all in the same room
they weren't looking at each other
though but they were in different
corners of the room and they just all
just corners that's weird I was one time
my cousin healthy yeah he jerked off in
the corner yeah but that's probably like
elementary school junior high right that
was junior high story yeah I had a
friend that he told me a story that when
he was younger it was like when he was
younger like teenagers
whatever they were all watching a porno
together so they're all facing this way
I'm not looking at each other but
they're like jerking and then they
started having contests who could like
who's calm ago the law I know guys get
all competitive he's come went the
longest no no but like he said that they
used to do that and I cuz I thought it
was weird that they would all be in the
same room watching the porno but they
were almost same room when we discovered
porn like in fourth or fifth grade we
used to do that [ __ ] too and then like
some of us don't know how to jack off so
we're like playing with our balls the
whole entire time you're part of that
like what like we're just watching porn
together and then like people start like
[ __ ] going like this like they're
[ __ ] trying to wash clothes on the
rack take it out [ __ ] you and women
don't like boys will like [ __ ] do
this and stick their hand in and start
doing this and then I remember like my
friends are fourth or fifth grade oh
yeah I remember my friends are like
can't cuz we had a TV in the garage with
couches and stuff it's so we're all a
lot like watching it and then we hear
the door and and one kid runs up and
[ __ ] turns off the thing and changes
the channel and in
she has a basket full of laundry and she
walks through and I was just there like
this and she's like speaking in Spanish
like why is your friend's hand in his
frickin pants like that and I was just
shocked so I couldn't move with my hand
like gripping my balls like this how
many people were there it was like three
or four of us yeah so weird that's like
wow how old is like fourth or fifth
grade yeah but at that time we were
[ __ ] around a lot like we would have
like like like like what do you call it
like a like a class meeting like during
audit or in the auditorium and my
friends would like have a rub off
contest and it'll just be like [ __ ]
rubbing like like I had one friend who
jacked off with this palm you guys are
[ __ ] chimpanzee its dick like like
this yeah no difference between boys and
monkeys for technique yeah I mean like
we're just explore and I guess and
trying to figure out what the best
technique is and we wouldn't even come
back then I mean I [ __ ] some couches
but I never did it together with people
house [ __ ] comes along you know have
any close it out of a couch oh yeah
that's you and I know someone else yeah
I let some couches really have ruined if
you have a teenage boy oh you're about
to have some ruined ass couches you get
one of these he's good because she's got
a bunch of cameras in around even if
they don't your counters are about to
have a meet two moment he'll say you two
you gotta get these kind of couches
where there's no like cushion the
cushion oh that's good you get the
pushing in the cushion what [ __ ] yeah
yeah I think you have to [ __ ] proof
you're conscious and you have to say to
the cabinets if I give to do that 14
years for that me
ask your mom you moms and the future
mama question then would you rather have
your kid [ __ ] a couch or would you
rather just buy them a flashlight so
they could just do it and they're a
privacy I'll save my couches I will know
how I fight in my house you probably be
too embarrassed the kids are really
embarrassed about that at that that age
I will not make it that way I think it's
all about the presentation
maybe this flashlight you'd like then
like everyone else and I don't want to
have him be like yeah they bought me
flashlights and then everyone's like
yeah no and then he's gonna go put your
finger in this it all the boys and go Oh
our Santa for dumb boys to put the
[ __ ] thing won't be so comfortable
with our boy do you know boys do you
know boys you get it boys boys would all
stick their fingers in that [ __ ] if
you're like all ten we are all curious
as [ __ ] even if someone came in there
yes they don't give a [ __ ] yeah we could
wash it out we are bored and you're
probably gonna [ __ ] pass around a
flashlight you're all [ __ ] but the trick
is to be a cool enough parent to allow
our son to also it's like it's okay you
got your flashlight right okay well want
to put in a dishwasher
keep it clean if you keep it on his hot
set that's true because you also know
how dirty boys are they're probably
gonna bust in it and if [ __ ] take a
nap and leave that fresh and if you care
about them they're not gonna clean them
clean it that's what you get
cuz I'm not for forests look I'm gonna
buy a dishwasher that's just fully
stocked the flashlights and all clean
all the time decisions dude if I'm
saying keep your decision I'm gonna keep
them all nice you have a separate
dishwasher you can cover a kitchen about
two dishwashers
flashlights give unrealistic depth ideas
two boys are better taken you can [ __ ]
the cops in many cases they're better
yeah yeah they should [ __ ] account
there's nothing that deep in the world
wrinkles Gannon only they're better it's
not better it's not better off in many
cases they're better and yeah I don't
want boys to get unrealistic death depth
expectations where they think all
vaginas are gonna be as deep as a flush
like this cuz that's unrealistic and it
gives poor better you know it makes you
feel shame see see how you feel ashamed
but cuz you said it's better a
flashlight didn't exist we would even
have this conversation which is
flashlights now after saying they're
better
[Music]